the new chairman of the conservative
party eager to stress he's very
different to the last one are your taxes
good morning they most definitely are
good morning how are you
do you think you win the next election
of course we will we can and we will a
hopeful message for a party in need of a
big turnaround Greg hands replacing the
sacked Nadine zahawi the first
appointment of Rishi sunak's first
proper reshuffle but even for those
involved this is hardly a dramatic
overhaul
Shuffle few fresh faces and one key
Survivor Deputy Prime Minister Dominic
Raab under investigation for bullying
keeps his job are you surprised you're
still there Mr Rob one more going
cabinet but this Shuffle more about
changing roles than Changing Faces the
Prime Minister creating four new
Whitehall departments revealing where he
thinks the government isn't delivering
Grant shaft in charge of a new
department for energy security and Net
Zero there's the latest in a growing
list of personal priorities for the
Prime Minister the changes to government
I've announced today will help us
deliver on those promises for the
British people particularly the creation
of a brand new first of its kind
apartment for energy security and Net
Zero so we can really focus on that
issue bring down people's energy bills
energy security delivered by a cabinet
minister on his third job in four months
serving alongside the six business
secretaries since the last general
election in 2019. so as we watch
familiar cabinet names slot into new
government job titles it's become clear
Rishi sunak decided that he was going to
undertake a pretty major restructuring
underneath the Bonnet of the government
and while he says that that's needed to
help deliver the people's priorities the
danger is that changing the way things
work just slows up his ability to get
things done
MP's worried the times the thing this
government doesn't have Sam Coates Sky
News Westminster